it Get It Started Welcome to party
Eindhoven 22
very happy to see so many Faces Here
some family of Faces some new Faces so
Gonna Be A Great Day Today ehm zo paidea
Payday that Fer this Years Twenty 22 Is
The Forest Edition of idea Eindhoven the
first  edition was Hotel By ASML eh and
we had such a good time there We Just
decided Keep Going Down in the second
edition We had really cool online
Event with last speakers eh and The
13th Edition last Year eh was actually
hosted Right Here at the high tea  Campus
Where we had about 250 signups so was a
big crowd
and this Year we Kind Of Blue past that
record I think we
signups Just for today eh Which really
cool ehm so to
Mark qcasion I'm gonna Take A Quick
Photo With Me and  everyone Here and the
next Year we gonna put it
on screen
so that When You Come Back not If When
I'm just a swimming everyone you can try
and Find Yourself
and it was also a Our socials so we
later Today you can see ever you  can
fi  nd yourself Eindhoven
[Music]
your part of something really Big
Who is this All Force so the whole
Payday that conference uh is part of
number Focus num focuses in organization
That supports a lot of Projects ehm you
Might know some of the Projects  from
opening up and New Python file and
infording panda's and one Pie ehm so all
the protes of today Acts League go to
num Focus and They distributed over the
packages making sure that is People get
paid And that is packages are mainteint
and updated so we can  continue using
Them for Our work
eh Force also want to address are
beautiful location Here Which is
provided to buy The High Tech Campus and
the Ai Innovation Center davic
graciously letters be Here And how is
this many of you and all of thiest
Amazing Talks There we  gonna have today
and of course we can't forget The
sponsors all the companies that Made
Possible Today um Without we really We
Could Pul this off like organization Why
the would Have  Been Nightmare to get
Everything painting stuff
so teaser all disponsores that you can
tank for today then What's the plant for
today ehm will quick we have 20 Talks
Today eh divided over 3 Tracks eh to the
will be three Talks at the same Time at
any Give  a moment One Of The Talks will
be rating this room and the otherium and
Upstairs There Is tomorrows For The
Other two Talks
ehm die otitu Rooms There is Limited
capacity so we have a medium room and a
small room to If There is specific Talk
you want  to Go see Make sure you get
there untime because One sits full It
full evergres gonna close The Doors
we also have really Great Boots so
Somewhere sponsors Are Here With Us
Today ehm and There's pred Out in the
room that you orangust eh Now outside be
shred  to visit These Boots Network with
thes companies and AST in about all the
amazing work that There's doing a so with
this Science
uhm but I also want to highlight is
there we have two really cool damage as
well  in eh Unox The Boots One Of The
demos is gonna show use some really cool
hardware eh with Michael controllers and
last flight eh I just Saw The setup It
It Looks really complicated really cool
en eh second demo wear you can go up to
the screen you  get a microphone You
answer couple questions And then You're
alter ego Here Inn herself will be soon
on this Queen in the form of Animal
Portrait Made Puzzle by the latest in
Imagine Generation Technology No More
about all about of the stings visit The
demos and  astimall About It is there
very Eagle to talk to you
ehm some Practical Thing this well at
the End of the day There also will be a
eh
eh Closing notes Right Here In This room
So be shirtje Come Back Here and the
otherium for the Closing notes  Which
will be followed by Food and Drinks
outside we can Network Talk to cheddar
talk to Summer the speaker And astum The
Question city you Might not have been
able to ask um Back to the information
also we have toilets  downstairs will
Upstairs with two This downstairs Don't
Forget You can not so Go Upstairs all
the talkshow So be available on the
paidea YouTube channel
so Make sure to connect to use via
LinkedIn and tweet at using at Pride and
Eindhoven or using The hashtag party
that Eindhoven on Twitter
dan eh Real Import Today we have to
Keynote speakers the first Will Be Right
after I'm done Talking so market Talk To
Us about Ai in atics he's reacts really
Expert on That We looking for To Here We
the has the same  and after lunch
alcome Back Here Again for Marijn Who's
gonna be Talking To Us about using Ai n
d Th for good in ways That We Might not
have though about before
ehm if you have Any questions concerns
her you need Any of comedy memories
so we have Gareth  Koen Michiel Andy And
Myself If You Need A she can find These
shirts you can not so find a valentier
wearing A Very Summer of shirt with sets
valentier on the back eh and Lay I can
also answer your questions or  If not
They Know How to find Us
Them before I mentioned uh
also thes 20 Talks There we have Today
ehm how do we Select this Talks well we
had about 70-8 Proposal Send In he's
were All Amazing proposals we write them
all and I think  each proposition was Red
with 67 people from a diverse background
to make this asfer as possible
ehm dan One Last Note I Was A Mansion at
the End of the day There is Another Talk
by Yannick he will be talking about an
initiive called Masters that connects
experienced  date Scientist with
political refugees to help Them home
There Day design skills They are coding
skills and Help him jumpstart A korear
indeda in analogend eh she has that
Sound interesting To You Make sure you
Can You Go see the talk by Yannick at
the end of Day
ehm then that Enough for me then I want
to as Mark to come on stage or First
Keynote speaker Mark is it Before an
Expert on atics Heaven The sup podcast
Beyond date signs that you can find on
all the Playstation  find podcasts I
Guess
to you oh this Great West de Clicker has
the power Right
By the way Thanks zo Good morning to
everybody
[Applause]
yes dan valve dan zoen huh you don't know
what I what I will Tell but Thank You
For inviting  Me By the way by Day really
cool to be her ehm yes so my take is
Mark Vermeulen I will we talking A
Little Bit Today about
ethics Ai The attic soft VI attic of
Technology actually bitmo brightley ehm
zo Maybe First little bit about myself
eh Who  am I very existential Question je
know when you think about it but I will
answer it in the in the Fashion Most
people Do It is addition something
about that profession Right so eh he
becomes for Cape AMG I'm A manager Within
die eh trusted Analytics  Team already counting
little bit more About what we do in the
next Light I'm There Ai and atics lead
Whatever There is very good at coming up
with this Fancy Names For proposals
don't think to much about it but
actually He has a background in
Endh  oven hey Zo he used to Study Here
Use the Study at the Eindhoven
University of the analogy eh dit
computer Science uhm i used to be a boy
member voor erased erased is die studio
sociation of met dematics en computer
Science en die technical university of
Eindhoven
Eindhoven  student e-sport and sociation
would student so play games essence
ehm If so he Lost some time in
Eindhoven more time that my parents want
to actually but Back Dani die things
not to pay The hol eh Study Long Back
in full show That's Why ik  always do
some alle Thanks eh savers really cool
please check Them Out sponsor Dump If
There's anybody Here With sponsor power
in the Ocean's please sponsor Them The
really cool Clap of People If so
basically out of this Everything I could in
my power to distract people from my
studies eh from studying ehm well he
has in Utrecht American eh in
Amsterdam Amstelveen he would Sometimes
Joke me Mind Is Blue with my heart is
still very much Red soa I  con City this
to be your home game really nice to be
back in Eindhoven ehm he wil Not Talk a
lottaboutcapeumg because not here to
promotive but Maybe very briefleet To
Give You A Little Bit of an Idea what
we do ehm
powdered here a nice sentence we
basically Make sure we help clines with
there a ICE Systems There machine
Learning Solutions to make surded These
are so put it her Fit for purpose
compliance en als so attackel eh Because je
is Just The Way of saying okay we helped
mix sure that There Systems doe  wat er
supposed to do that they keepdoing what
er supposed to do that they are Loud te
doen wat er doing en als so have Give In
That I Can Do It For Me technical
respectively dat ik arlow To Do It For Me
Legal perspective shoot den also  Do It
Right that is die attical Dimension to a
i machine Learning Systems ehm Do I want
to eh develop dissolution Right ehm
That's The attical Question ehm Zoe
help a withert and who basically
help little ones about me Je  trying to
see is useful suspects Before that
he is about principals eh Explain Ability
account Ability blablabla eh yes Who
helps him when I put a Translation To How
Can You put is nou wheelie into practice
eh eh Explain Ability Okay explainable
with respect to Who Right And How far  Do
you have to take this concept is
difficult questions we help Lian Switch
wear like in the Ai govana's business zo
te speaker wishmentligation eh so That's
What I Do It captmg ehm dat is even Look
at Watson de Manu Zo he got three
topics for you today  al do my best the
cofferdam in eh 206 minutes will be a
challenge met Let's cr-vrican Get First
Evil Talk little bit about the attic of
a y en uhm kan een convincial Het is NOS
not necessarily new ehm al involved a
little bit about Freedom in  Society and
finally Abel Talk little bit about it
works that date Science is not Science and
he will also Talk a little Bitter Bout
That there is no objective Truth in the
world like start the bitm  ark technical
en wil old
anton  for the Beekse Bergen would
for the box of you don't know the
Beeksebergense Zoo in a Netherlands and the head
The Great he diaso Let's die Velp an
app and Wits the user The visitor of the
Zoo could scan Animals of the Zoo And then
comes  collect all of them eh in a white
or we Pokémon Go type Fashion eh You
Could eh scandi Animal This is an image
recognition System of course A model
Deep Learning and herrel net that was
ehm om device en de user couldnq collect
al die Animals and get  a badger
Something Right uh pretty cool Idea so I
work on that with eh with some College
nou
bell
eve the toptree results and it should be as the user
Hey is this the giraffe you know ehm the
top teens worlds with the most
confidence and then evertink Goes has
the user labels eh the results are Yes
this is so giraffe and we would than Use
the  label data Again for Future training
hey so like If You machine Learning
engineer It's like the wet Dream
Right of Any machine Learning project hey
So you have automated feedback loop ehm
yes this was ar-scension so what Ender of
happening well afterwell The People  are
in herty Lazy Right so People didn't ehm
Only Take pictures of The Animals
because Sometimes The Animals ren of
Visible or they're like Just Want to
badge so People start iteking pictures
of the Science Of The Animals
interne about is weather not we  shoot
allow this data than in ar new training
data Because you could make an argument
that on the one hand It is an accurate
The piction Of The Animal itselfright
die is pictures are useless Photo
realistic u  h Special In This case he said
an okapior Something but the
orderhands animals Osso Don't Want Your
machine Learning Bundle to become
vinegar post detector essence Right hey at
alarms 2 match of this new data in the
training data
something like this around the legs build This I  believe
four louded but uh witsome hesitation
Bah I had Worse then Yes I know your people
People Star the drawing pictures of The
Animals or the souvenir shop eh You have
those Little pussy's eh ehm eh and this
will be I don't know if There We Just Lazy
or a testing on model
en je je je was een Free Free Monkey
stress test against but surprising the
unmodle was extra performing really well
So if you would take a picture of a
tiger pushe It actually Said Hey this is
probi a tiger Dat was een good Thing  but
This Is Keine Where we draw a line we're
like Okay Maybe we don't want this you
know This is really gonna This is a
classical Case of data poisoning Sans
die Right hey so your training date we
have compoisent so we  didn't allowed this
but I talte Was A Pretty Fun development
nou Viber reso kinon is so He was
activally monitoring the data People
smithit eh he will too Kind of Crazy
things By the way Don't Ask but um ja
dan talk about it with  eh wie were
wheelie King on preventing this data
poisoning Well it was us the case eh am
again developing this app This was Keine
In The Way of Maybe of eh cyndis Kendall
so was I believe in 2015 Google
release that is Public Amish recking
mission eh  algorithms or in API for it
online uh detect al Kind of Shape tried
Cars airplanes eh or vering liquids of
Animals ehm Bikes A parently and then
I was Guy How is the middle the picture of
his and eh and is Friends and the system eh
label ladies  Being Gorillaz Well this is of
course very hurtfall unwanted situation
to be in ehm yes de call it racist
algor Willems please Forgive Me hey die Us of
the term algorithm and you all Know It's
A model of course but I Just Go With
with the media term  very huh  rtful
situation Is Not what you want wie were
very Key on perfenting the same scaryo
ik als je ken een Mansion eh is data is
is pictures of People sleep in your
training data en de Beekse Bergen
oswresten gorilla wie kan Easily en up
in the same snario  Well the solution of
Google was Simply to remove The gorilla
class al Together zo If You There algor
Williams there is no gorilla anymore and
we Kind of dit the same ehm
maar je think about it not really the
right solution because anybody knows
this Who works in  machine Running if you
have a machine Learning image system is
Like A Hammer Right so everything
Everything at Seas is Nails If you don't
want it this see Something If There's A
shirt in classy don't want to see you
are doing something with You  Shoot You
Shoot train it on that Class Right so
what we shouter then we shoot actually
af activally Gadget pictures of Humans
dus system goed werk ik nice a human as
search and then Say Something like I
don't do this  right now very happy this
picture is eh is on its way Eh is for
my phone from Yes Today en in the
latest release of the App The actually
dit exactly this Ah Then he has a
red-bit i submed a this picture terwan
de Both me in the  app en now you get a
correct output Say Hey your problemly
True picture of a friend of Yours eh a
bit means The Gorillaz Back and the
ult so trained The model on eh Let's say
The Human Class eh de edit zo This Is XD
a good way  to prevent the snario nou you might
thing
the Tap doesn't
work On The Toilet or this case the
essenti the same Problem right now I
would like to dry attention to this on
the left zo what you see Here account
Shirley Cards eh The Renate of an
employ of Kodak in no Kodak eh  the the
company de produces photo fe  e en en
cameras and Every takes after empoli
Cult Shirley eh White woman eh Color
reference Cards Meaning There are used
to calibrate Skin Color Back eh when you
tevelop eh pictures a photographs in
the 1940s the Problem die is color
reference Cards where Only for well The
Only featured A White woman Meaning Mimi
Maybe of Cindy spectious Before ehm het
het letter to black people Being barrely
Visible om pictures he mabiosini's
pictures of je on The Ice you know or
Maybe eh teet don't like this picture
bit Hurt full met dit was  Basically the
closet because die Shirley Cards per Only
featuring A White woman ehm my Think
About It This is China the same Problem
Right is Just the new instants of the
same problem hey of course Digital of the
eventually softis progn on the left but
when you think  about it all issues with
Technology in thescapes like hey racist
technologies and just as Charlie new
by the way
Kodak eventually fixtis on the left hey
did Started distr  ibutions Cards als
people with darker Skin pigmentation so
anybody One have a Go at this way
wear wel actually
They got complains but not by people
from eh
wat je doen de Cry but actually from
companies that manufacture chocolate and
furniture companies at manufactured
furniture met very Dark Wood There are
complaining Hey My commercials are Barry
Visible eh But I customers but I could
zumers cannot see my chocolate Friends
and that was the reason at Kodak
eventually fix this hey And that Because of
the
political blablabla I'm not really
buying this because no Shirley Cards koe
de featured a large of Right of Skin
Color Right And exit that actually  what
they dit eventually So how can
Technology be in reisently atacle
pelatical en dan deed I Would say Okay
Fair Enough nou conceal Princess thi  s
consider frenches de
teknologisch je nog nuclear Power If
You assassan Society adopt the
technology of nuclear Power die has
never Choice but also except die technos
Scientific autocratic Elite dat Comes
with it and also amillitarya taroty Why
nuclear energy is Simply to Dangerous
of the Technology to  ehm govern in eh
democratic The centrifice Fashion Right
if you as Society adopt nuclear Power you
have no Choice but all so to adopt
centralized Chain Of Command hey of
Scientist that Nobody doing
here
basically sacrificing Safety or Sorry
Freedom for Safety as a post for instant
More inherently distribute decenter life
technologies hey like so lock Power but
nuclear Energy a Simply to Dangerous ehm
en dit is hot True for lottovies wat we
Call in Dutch system technology hey
system technological Ground  Skill
technologies like chips or or trains
Real ways This is if we actually w  at
Plato already nou huh Plato famous
perform philosopher
je it was very big om demoracy for dos
Of You Don't Know he dinner really like
the moxy zo he me the comparison with a
ship hey Je kan dat de ship of state die
Set a ship  can not have to many captains
eh Els things go wrong he don't know
Which way to go and the same holts for
certain technologies like nuclear Power
having inherent centralized autoritarian
ehm kernal so to speak
topics you have to like this pend Money
under eh put Research  to ehm and you do
even have to subscribe to all of them
Right friendstance eh Safety huh or
crust because here now Clear worked to be
Safe in the Saint Fashion you don't want
your Ey to go Hey Right huh Je think what
yourself driving Cards  to go eh crashing
into things eh military useitch Right
Said The Again Every Actual team eh of
course we have the threat of nuclear
weapons in the Same Fashion be af The
Thread of killer robot Ride of atonomus
eh drone's for instance also Big  topic
that wearance Research And Fire mental
impact hey you can be concerned about
Frances nuclear waste en die impact of
the environment in the same Fashion you
can be concern about Frances the power
used hey die is Grand Skill uh Networks
Us in de cloud en finally als  we
existential Risk eh there Good Reasons
To Be eh concerance about general
artificialogence eh
nuclear bomb
Where is the app because Scientist Where
not a 100 % sure that the nuclear bomb
wooden Trigger A Night of the reaction
he basically becomes A Night the whole
atmosphere so i can do the funny miss you
retair Research The Wasa Non Zero
propability and this this  de met 13
hydroom woodent ignite The atmosphere zo
in de Same Fashion hey general Artificial
talent is to Some People Bit of eh
Science ficti  only topic but the
potential impact Out ways of course de
propability so It's It make Sense to the
mods so to speak ehm well wie aunt dat
het bit about inherent political ethical
technologies where I want to race you a
couple More some you see and Day live
This Is What I call forms of Invisible
Barb Wire
zo die's are technologies dat dan kinda
hardcode it into Society that Limit
your Freedom when some capacity zo One
Of The example Give rds huh put those
taxi gate al station huh die is
fancis zo Why is it uh  I believe It's
also in Eindhoven de case beserten in
Utrecht I cannot Go through the station
or I cannot go to the Starbucks or I can
not shop lingerie het The station en dan
blowing People do that but That's Just
for the Shake of argument say you  want
to do this I cannot do that Without an
OV Cards Right
so highways hey highways ehm yes
you sign that one from a to be hey at the
same Time also prevention from going to
see you know If There's No Highway you
can't Go There or a This Is bloody
difficult to go There hey so You're  Being
It some Shape of from Being Yes je
control by Highway salt peak Inter Sting
Idea of ​​Thinking about it
endsmann Elftal like again because the Bottom right
ehm so this is a Fancy in Utrecht
Weide helice is fans Here Right what he
is bloste perdashion Area
to access  the road If I want to Right
It is fences no Reason for Being there
still it restrict me in my Freedom very
weird fans ehm you guys think about is
a Daily Life but Sorry with this Fancy
Be There hey So This are Forest of wat
he Call  Invisible bardwire en hope you
can see of course The analogy with
algorithms and dettification and trying
to make zo If You Still not convince by
this ehm
I Love The
Streets of Paris by the Paris Beautiful
City dat is anybody Know Why The Streets
are so white hey
hahaha
to barricate a small Street en Fight The
Police is again in a narrow coreyder of
course if you hey your White Street it
but is easy  to get surrounded hey at the
military and this is hey This Is reform of
Technology in this case are Road that
have is an embedded at the
conplitical Dimension hey Take that or Napoleon who
lives and then Kwel protest quel rioters
and This is for interesting that The
Yellow Jacket protests hey Back Duran
Corona this quiet ehm perfected at this
hey It was mush easier for the police In
Paris and the military 2 Strike Them Down
Hey come with the Water Guns very very
interesting Okay so Who had notice It
about he restrict  test technology well
Let's talk little bit about Freedom Now
die die op is het zo voor me die appen
of Freedom is this hey Deezer caled
desirepad zo in dutcher side
elephant horses he Thing There The
Beautif  ul I love Them because Their an
epitom of Freedom you don't take
Freedom has much More to do with you
having The Ability To Break The Rules in
set of Just doing Whatever you want
Right that is not Freedom I will talk
about it in the second  but
useri want Ends of happening is the
least penalty brush Down sum Kind of
fans Ride or en van die paaltjes je nou
ver je nooijing with your bike and I go
True Them hey die want to control the
flow of traffic Again thy want to eh
restrict  jordanomy en wat People then do
They Walk a Long sided en usually you
and up in an adverzario relationship
white municipality in middle-ganna put
en Down More Fantasy know like
her love is it Harderwijk and I
can do it well More fans Is You Gonna go
around Them Again de put Down Another
fans and some Point The get a Right This
Is Beautiful This is really Freedom so
als die Appetit or treating Ja you
having The abilit Break The Rules and in
sometimes Shape of form This is XP design
pr  ovement eh already Here so
yearsley do the coins game favor Yours
Say Hey this is design sucks I'm actually
Gonna Make it better um and There eh Arc
there Terms to preventure are
uselessolish if no I really like
desireparts Beautiful actually Eindhoven
as one of the  most famous design Parts
there are those with that know where it is I
think most Of You Maybe Walked on it and
Ever Go Ahead is
Limbo pad Yes Smart audio
Inside open in which the Limbo pad the Limbo
pad is huh for Josephile how do you suppose
that  die end over University of the
nationalis Ja je Old walkthund dessert a
little too part from the sensor station To
Die Eindhoven University of the English
Comes Right nou This Was XD Farm dit en
used to be Here Now It's Made out of
concrete and blablabla didn't  it wasn't
there in the past hey so actsley people
from Limburg and who can limbo him
die Walks from the Central Station
when the University and actually They Use
To Be Physical Barbier There hey the
least pa  llity The City Of end over
Dylan wanddem to walk There put it en
het zon point of Time I believe die end
over University bottland and They Food
Down this road en of course nowadays is
used for things like the intro eh en dit
eh dat kan de  stuff ehm They were vouch
Path huh So if we explains White
ghostly Sneek and Koos Up and Down
And blablabla I can't write them down already eh that
mirror of Limburg at Walking On The
Grass and knows The Beautiful example of
des provenment of Freedom well
on the  spectrum of course
befint things like this Hey so who pay a
price for increase datification en
automation in Ark the site die zo
using Desire pass is actually Being a
critical Tinker hey your user critical
Thinking to enforced design improvement
so to speak ehm bottom of the
spectrum  of course West things like this
I don't know Events really True but I
check multiple size het Beer To Be True
like this Belgium woman hoe drove to
croatia als je Only hat Hoe pick  -up or
friends from Brussels Center station I
believe or Japanese too Is drives Into
Lake ehm ja Willy happened a party Yo
this happens when you you Lose critical
Thinking hey you know Okay computer 6s are
on blind die Follow what what the computer
said so die  skilling in the Sense with
the cannot SO of course Bee Evil More
Hurt full eh People can actually die of
course All No the example of Uber eh Hoe
hoe kilt eh bedestring eh met als we dit
Guy your panty drier Of A Bridge en is
navigation system  eh for that was an
update by Something stil talte Was A
Bridge There huh So This is the cost of
privacy PS essenti for in Trees
dating and Losing your builty does
dv8 van de pad eh That's essence what
occasion Das eh in all the new huh  You
can also in Google Maps eh traffic gems
Now a Days I Told This one was Pretty
funny eh in Which People hacked fake and
those are all those taxis to the cmotel in
the Center of mashedgo and to buy Mars
was Block Nobody Good uh enter an  ymore I
think Marijn wants to tell bitmour about
Russia later so she pretty cool this
guy Who created er a fake Google Maps
traffic Jam at carrering Around 99 cell
phone you know deez are the undesired
side effects of data Vacation Right so
eh yes ver Beautiful Okay so  he wonder
Talk Little Bit Freedom ehm iwel die
Mansion eh zo viedum is not doing What
Every Whatever how you want Freedom
hashmir to with having ubility To Break
The Rules or en join Something against
your Will I can give a very Easy example
by this by Memes  of this is called ehm
dialectics is she Fancy Way that som
verloskus it seems to duscribe The Course
of History I can give you very Easy
example and think sugget this in the
meet Time I have bonus here
Let's se you want to be a farmer hey
Eindhoven  farmers your walker farmer and
Let's Zoom me your start for my
Society With No Rules no Real so
regulations nou You Are Free to be a
farmer Right you I can up some land have
holdts on Animals  you my Think You're
free but then some bendits come along and
There like Ja wie like your Milk We like
your Money and you like yeah but I don't
wanna give to you and There like you
have but we have Guns Okay That's The
shame zo you You're Not had There
Freedom to be abanded is a beaning on
your Freedom to be a farmer eh zo This
Is Use the what we call The teases eh
teasers is the curn situation The current
Idea en that usually Out Of The yter  sum
Kind of reaction such Kind of response
That's What We Call The entities in this
case is Would Be The Bandits Right ehm
so u me be like Oh wait a minute this
is not really en gucciation Maybe we
not the police we not the police  Force
hey so Dennis som Kind of resolution and
the conclusion Could Be Okay We Need To
enforced The Police in Society thanks
Jef Another Problem Because if you have
the police Yes die deny some funding hey
so in those texts sprobably eh is om
Kind of sandflies form  of government Who
Are then again i  n peaning on your
Ability to be a farmer eh zo under a
government a centralized System of Of
Command your All so not free totally
Free to be a farmer Right en of course
this pyros on aspiros on Spyro's on eh
some pointje get nites and Texas en
blablabla eh So you are never 100% free
but freedomish More to do with Being
free with respect to unfree them eh You
can Only find Freedom in Un Freedom
South speak ehm This Is Guy on the left
Hey go he talt of this He is basically
the  Guy Thierry baudet chair die All For
Minerva from ehm Maybe die see
that Before is is argument is basically
You Can Only really value weight or game
Knowledge after Something Else happened
hey you can never really There's No
reshion of Base to protect The futures
of the  speaker because Only look back
This Is White Cherry but Every Fine
incorrect Manor or so you wanna No
More about that talk to me later and
happy to Talk About That Way Thierry
baud
you my Think um yeah But Now It Is N  ow
It this video really fashioneel hey to be
ehm Francis your Boss Is Now your
friends Right hey and ehm the Classic
autory Terry and patriarkle Father Figure
hey Louis van Gaal It's Little Bit Out Of
Fashion nou bij dit Oud daten blablabla
eh actorietarian but I would  like to
potion disc Question eh under Witch are
you whitchen are you are you more free
so I Would Are you a More free Un a
Louis van Gaal dan Michael Scott eh so
True is that so Imagine after classical
autoritarian patriarkle Father Figure
Right and not telsu  Sun Daughter you're
gonna visit Your grandma this weekend
you Might be like No I wanna play video
games we want the Wanda Do It And those
six Yeah I'm your dad you're going to your
grandmother are you mights few Is as a
form of unfreated and in some respect It
this Right because he makes Decision For
You nou concealer de modern postmodern
Father hey he's your friend Same with
your Boss hey Je bos doesn't tell you to
do something anymore your Boss kindl  y
ask you for help Right This is the Singing
so the post modern Father with say
santorder He knows that for Shoe I ca
n't make you but be going to grandma and
She Wood really offers Is A Point It If
you don't want to go  and uh Imagine How
many Times you were Only sear in in your
Lifetime you know
It Sounds like you have Choice but you
really don't have a Choice Right die
outcome is exactly the same your going
to your grandmother acceptly in the
second scenario your also  all to
voltarely go to the grandmother eh So
You have to basically the
post modern totalitarian Father op bos
is not only aussing you to do something
asking you to do it out of your own
eh Preferably At The authorizing Father
Figure You're Free to  protest hey go to
grandma like this You The total consumption
faller That's a lukewarm for the isimbit
bosses It's very This is a sealot in
Society so is ehm if I'm there myself a
Witch scenario am I More free ehm Same
coach for Technology hey  so um
[Muz  iek]
join the Cold War ehm hey the coating of
totally nearest is and will be Bro Down
with the Deventer microdip hey People
smile Wood must like this quote would here
was here was really a Techno Optimist
and he was actually Right at the time hey
so  lol or die technological Spec then
Had A Very in Herent liberal de
centralized character like Hé like the
Early internet eh Love technologies Back
dan How's Old a Planes is Frances Where
in favor of More Freedom Martin Society
but if you compared to Lot of
technologies Now nou  with this not necess
Shirley at the benefit of the Invisible
eh such a lot of the machine Learning
base Systems eh How
arrive@generalizations beast to brush
historical data eh and patriots in that
they arrive generalizations not really
invaver of the individual ehm eh
seems sum  som examples en
cryptic of this is very difficult hey
So has i cried Technology
jolting doing sayer so Why is
that Ja That's Because of regan thi  s is
because we in the West
mistakeingly ikweed societal progress with
technological Pro Quest so I was
to criticize Technology you were think I
was criticing Society The process of the
side die Wishes not the same and This is
All Around Us
smartphone in the smartphone  there
is already eh loaded eh a Prison
Precision in Dare hey smartphone zo How
can you be Os Against the smartphone what
do you do about Hè wat your Crazy but I
telia Jeff The Caribbean Black Box
around you ever Town you go and your
location and data's  Being transmitter to
Third party's we date The Mind at the
blabla That's a Sounds show peeling
anymore Right so you get a leadhoff
labeling Again There's a lot of ideology
in disgusting technologies ehm keep me
then Time do a quick bitmo Time
or Not
I One Minute
sites is in Science in one minute what
would We Do
five minutes
Okay so of the Talk very very briefley
about date Science and the Nature Of
Truth so I will Ready Just mention  Right
To Die is datefight Systems machine
Learning Systems at Rive at
generalizations Right There not
necessarely at the benefit For Us The
Invisible eh because extra Who business
case for auto met de station en
datification by the we don't have an off
time in  of Resources order Special
Simply toe complex vers to a Right the
something in the Visual determination That's
Why we Us statistics eh That's Why we
generalize Any fure part of
manority distribution or eh Any arbitrary subgroup
for this seriously still in on data Ja die
Systems are not  nesody at your benefit
nou i used to be this guy hey so I
actually Use the machine engine Er is
actually stir de daten untilmate Sense
He was tuning Hyper promoters I don't
know why Oh This one seem to work ok
That's Us this distance feature  I don't
know why but it works and This is with this
are so just said the Science in the
traditional Sense so When we think of
Science in the traditional sensei think
of false fire  ability huh sign
harry potter test that should always be true
because date its only has to be through
enough it that science only need to
produce action on the insights for given
business case to acton it doesn't
actually have to be true true in the
sense  that for inches The Lawson date
Year a true Always except Maybe extreme
cases huh Who lives the who lives
Scientific True to be Always True wel
date the truth producers dat Science
are pregmatic Local Truits that is also
this guy Francis galton die was die eh
kasin  or eh Charles Darwin eh The Guy
from eh Natural Evolution this guy
bloody Genius he talt op eh told of
correlation eh regression regression to
the mean Wisdom of the Crowd al die
statistical conceptual very Family Red
this guy tot of Alphen en die is of
course accepte  en very large
evolutionary element To It Right en
There many e Elements to be Found in
statistics en in de date Science of
course evolutionary algor Williams eh
Creative The Sand vario  us evolutionary
inspired Concepts nou Evolution is a
difficult topic Because if you Evolution
To Be True then you have no Choice
protect that you are cognit effecties hey
your Believes the things we see the
things we think have not
evolved for Jack of Truth fining de
has evolved soli for Survival and
reproduction damage dample Let's Zoom
this forgass Believes eh zo Everytime
this Frog sees a Fly the Frog things
yummy must eat Nice
good for you Frog Maybe and concealer de
Frog on the left the four on the left
things Every Time is  She's this Little
Black dot he things A Princess I'm gonna
Kiss the Princess I'm Gonna Be A Prince
again Know It's
bunkers  Booth of them
the Fitness is equil right It Was A
Matter Boat of them reproduce and
survive and The Offspring Problem things
the same Thing zo Again thishoot
Question die Truth of your Beli  eves hey
your Believe struction this april
tractions in your brain your cocktail
effectives have not even project Of
Truth fining Everything we think My be
bunkers As long as it's adaptable hey and
favorite of reproduction s Survival so
between the cree weather Always in Pokémon go
and Think  About It Pokémon Go ets is awk
Mentos reality Layer Right On Top of
objective reality but We are never in
contact with Jack this reality we
are always receiver reality True this
filter eh True this lens are reality is
Pokémon Go eh We are not in the
objective world We are all this in the
Pokémon Go World Because We have no
Choice but the interact with objective
reality wie kennel do that uh zoal de
Meaning die subscribe To The World Is
Always through the Lance of this
subjective filter in on Minds ehm again
I  don't even Knows Time To foolishly Explain
all of this but the after Forgive Me and
have you got that talk about it at Great alanks
eh join the Break but
then i stood who this is  true Because
The already talk about the concept of
Freedom Right this general objective
concept but Freedom is not is a priori
conceptets der to begin wit en Stet
what we understand orthinkerbout Freedom
Is after all rate reactive Barrier
collector subjective interpretation
Right if you want frenches more left
or writeling that determines what Freedom
is eh so that Universal is determent with
the subjectively samed Science is my Final
Slide there we also have close off I
know I'm dropping somebombs Here with the
fact speak of himself is a non-sense
statement eh  facts Never speak of
'em even facts Always necessary have to
be subjectified Meaning The after be
upted by Scientist signific institutions
en Osso a dispoint weather facts Science
Scientific Street become under minable
and we know this to retrie Duran Corona
The facts in one country Red Different
from the facts Another accountry and
That's Kind of weird the Fat Of Tomorrow
a Different from the facts of  Yesterday
hey so When We change the facts Change
and finally Believe Science Well this is
the True statement Because We Can Ever
no Science We Can Only Believe Insight
kasvicover no It okay
thrown up I see the organization Getting
nervous Don't worry Little recap erm ik
go for the Lot of Ground ehm treadish
Feeding Only to be Found in Freedom such a
next time je forest All shoot to do
Something do it Maybe under Pro test
with that least be happy About It hey you
can you can do it like this you  can
disagree eh Challenge your Believes eh
Looks Might be the sea things Oh hey
Kiss of Frog eh you know what My
Happiness We Are Prince For Princess and
finally I would like to Curse you all to
walk on the gross so please take as many
shortcus As  You Can Live eh This one is
here to the high tea Campus he does it
picture Just then please walk on this One
en if so when your coding or making at
design so cloth For A shirt Cut the
Might XP design on the malization so we
become  all  e head free en half an hour
tankje so much
hahaha
[Applause]
talk about it
ja
Thinking with
interims of Freedom and Ai like this Ai
tools They are coming so
Do you actually have Some Kind Of
Control over This is if we say we don'  t
want to use this system like nuclear
Energy You are Some Kind of case do we
actually have a joy Something no someone
Else will do it and then we and it is
Advantage when you Thinking but that go
your making a reference to essentially
in Arms race  or that can do that in
business pedal so Just Society in
general
an Europe There is a lot of
happening on this the main maybe
your family with the ai-act in on
a European commity That's Being I
think Being launch It 2025 I think
Europe is really profiling It itself as
doing Ai in in Right Way eh in athical
Way that is there niche I Would say
America's More Of The on the commercial
business Side of Things China is more on
the
Ja collected Side of Things eh
zou eh de pencer  is becoming  niece you want to
uh to work with I think it make Sense
for Europe to eh delphne deep in Eye
convenants en en wiskity gayation eh dat
is really so that stuff video with kpng so
Andries in stuff I few think you wanna
talk to Marker about you  can do that in
the Bricks You're Around They albirout
and I hope you all effe supercool Great
conference I think so much and
[Applause]